brien people want to know what is your
morning routine as you know I'm known to
be a highly productive person I speak a
hundred times a year I write four books
a year I run three businesses I travel
all over the world people say how do you
do it well I have a morning routine and
I developed this a long time ago and it
really works what I do is I always get
up two hours before my next my first
fixed appointment so let's say I have a
phone call at eight o'clock then I get
up at 6 a.m. if I actually be in the
office at 8:30 I'll get up at 6:30 it's
always six 6:30 maybe earlier if
necessary but always two hours before my
first appointment then the first thing I
do for the first 30 minutes is I
exercise and I'll do stretching
exercises all do yoga exercises
sometimes I'll get up a little earlier
and I'll do aerobic exercises on life
cycle or elliptical machine or treadmill
or a swim I usually swim every single
morning but for the first 30 minutes get
your body working and then I like coffee
then I'll do a little bit of spiritual
reading and I'll just relax and get my
mind ready for the day and then I'll get
started within 60 minutes of getting up
I've exercised prepared my mind showered
dressed so I'm ready to go
then I have the next hour to plan
prepare have breakfast and get to my
first appointment so give that a try get
up two hours early exercise for the
first 30 minutes to get yourself going
read a little to prepare your mind and
then be ready to go one hour before you
have to be somewhere thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I'm
curious to know what did you learn from
Brian do you like is one your routine
can you apply something to your own
morning routine leave it down in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion also what do you think about
this series this morning routine series
is kind of on the bubble she would
continue it or not replace with
something else I'm open to ideas leave
it in the comments I'll be paying
attention thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you so I hope that
you continue to believe and whatever
your one word is I'll see you soon
you